hey everybody justin hartley here i'm
with buzzfeed and i'll be reading some
of
your thirst tweets
[Music]
i have added this is us to my watch list
solely because of justin hartley well
that's very sweet
i'm glad you added it to your watch list
but i will tell you
there are a ton of other reasons to
watch the show the writing
uh the other actors on the show the
stories all that's it's the best show
uh on the planet it has been for what
will be going into our fifth year now oh
my god justin hartley on passions was
how i knew
i was gay well great congratulations
i take that that's a that's a wonderful
compliment oh my gosh look at this
justin hartley has been
sexy since he was fox crane you all
remember passions you could forget
passions like goofy show um are these
all coming from the same person
you all retweeted this so justin hartley
can see this and be my next baby daddy
well
how many baby daddies do you have listen
i don't use the word daddy lightly i
don't either
but hear me out old kevin from this is
us yeah well
that guy's a stud i thought that i
looked in that makeup a lot older than i
was supposed to look
for for how old they were trying to make
me but i thought it looked phenomenal
justin hartley could slap me in the face
and i would beg for more my goodness are
these millennials
slap i'm not slapping anybody in the
face i would never slap anybody in the
face this one says justin hartley please
please please
punch me in the throat i mean i could do
that i'm not going to slap anybody i'll
i'll
punch this guy in the throat let me see
i can get an address here justin hartley
aka kevin from this is us is at my
restaurant and my legs stopped working
my pants are damp for some reason and my
head just did a 360 spin
a lot of the exorcist and my knuckles
locked and my tongue is dry in fact my
whole
mouth is dry i'm seeing black spots that
is descriptive
it could just be your dehydrated whew
justin hartley really aged like fine
wine
still hot in his 40s well thank you very
much i
you know this is the thing though um is
40 is like the new 30 is it not
justin hartley is one of those men who
just gets better looking with age
tasty mofo i crushed on him as oliver
queen but now
damn that's great you know a lot of
these people are are saying things about
my age and and being very complimentary
it makes me wonder if they're just
taking pity on me
i'm not that old justin hartley and his
chiseled jaw
makes me swoon that's great news this is
this this has got to be like my family
sending these or something something's
going on here mental note must watch
emily owens md for justin hartley see
this is a show
that i feel is is way underrated i
appreciate that tweet i wonder where you
could find emily owens md now i wonder
if you could find it on like netflix or
something i am informed now that um that
you could find it on netflix and then
netflix canceled it as well so
double cancelled this one says i would
love for justin hartley to suffocate
me with those i this is come on i'm
gonna finish that one i'm not doing any
of those things what's the next one
someone wants me to murder them i know
this is this is just an is an emotional
show
but i would love for justin hartley to
super mario smash my
what is happening with all these people
this person wants me to do illegal
things to them i'm only in my 40s i
don't think i should be reading this
wow well that was a lot of fun thank you
and um i'm glad at the end there i did
get humbled that was really great i
should have stopped at like 12. i'm just
quickly rereading all of these
memorizing these criminals
[Music]
you